joining us now the former Sixers beat
writer now sports columnist for the
Philadelphia Enquirer in philly.com and
today's column is 76ers need Joel embiid
back after home loss to Miami he's Bob
Ford who joins us bob thanks for joining
us update us on Joe LM Bede's injury and
what did you make of his tweet after the
game well it's not the most outlandish
tweets that are made by high-profile
people in this country these days but he
was injured he underwent surgery
approximately two weeks good repair an
orbital bone fracture and the process
was two to four weeks and so or two
almost three weeks out now right before
the series started he said if it was my
decision
I would probably play but actually I
wouldn't say that because I don't think
I'm ready to play because it doesn't
feel right and then the day later he
said we're buying time for me make sure
I'm all the way back I give them a lot
of credit and then as you said Dan last
night after they lost the game he said
he was sick and tired of being babied so
I'm on Instagram so I'm not I'm not sure
where Joelle's head is and I'm not sure
where his orbital bone is but he thinks
he's ready to play and I think they
might might be time to give him a chance
there Dan but whose call is this well
it's not Joe else the medical staff for
the Sixers has for several years now
really really run things that includes
the sports and conditioning people and
the analytics people on the load
management people and you know when Ben
Simmons sat out the entire year last
year he went though he was probably
going to be okay to play in the latter
part of the year that's all the medical
people who run it it's not the coach
it's not the players and that's been
very very clear over time
you think he starts game three I do I at
least think he's going to play now he
hasn't played basketball in two weeks so
there's a little bit of game
conditioning that he's probably enough
to work his way into I think you are
going to see him in Game three yes do
they if they won last night do we see
Joe LMB actually I think so yes I think
either way you would see him and I'll
tell you why then
if they had one last night particularly
if it had been in as an emphatic of
fashion as they had won Game one then
you're already looking ahead to the next
series a little bit a little bit not to
disrespect the heat but because to
nothing and Miami getting beat probably
would have said okay this this might be
over so then you start thinking about
the game conditioning for embiid as
you're looking with an eye no pun
intended to the next series and then
maybe even the next series where you're
really really going to need them and
then if you lose the game last night you
lose a home game you know Sixers were
only one of three teams to the league
this year to win 30 home games in the
regular season they're very very good at
home now things are a little bit
different and Dwyane Wade has awakened
that team and that was at a very very
impressive showing by him last night
28 points off the bench so now you don't
want to go down to one now you might
need that guy and you need it
particularly at the defensive end of the
court where Miami is sort of having its
way in the paint well also that but you
know you had guys who were just living
on the perimeter last night and dying on
the perimeter for Philadelphia last
night so there's no inside presence
there whatsoever now granted you keep
Whiteside on the bench but if you give
me my druthers I'd rather have embiid in
there to give me some offensive
firepower as well instead of relying on
these guys bomb and threes yeah and Erik
Spoelstra did the only thing he could
the Sixers made 18 of 28 in Game one
from three which is ridiculous they
weren't gonna do that again but that
killed the heat so small stir did the
only thing he could as he just painted
the three-point line with players and to
do that you have to ignore the paint and
with joelle and beat in there you cannot
do that so as you suggested you know you
would though I'm saying that's a
defensive force in Miami is shooting
much better than the Sixers have allowed
during the season it that offensive
presence you simply can't ignore the
paint with him there and then you can
spread the floor and get your wide open
looks and they did not get those last
night as you suggested shot horribly
from 3 7 for 36 and you know Miami
pulled one out and it's a series now
what are the expectations you know
postseason expectations
well Dan they changed a little bit when
they won 16 games in a row to end the
regular season I would I would say you
know this is a team that in late
December was 15 and 19 so expectations
have come very very quickly and for them
to turn that around and win 52 games and
then finish as they did including the
last eight games of the regular season
without embiid they have a guide in
Simmons who's probably the Rookie of the
Year probably should be the Rookie of
the Year it's very exciting and people
are still sort of riding the crest of
that Eagles Super Bowl here in
Philadelphia it's been a long time
between drinks of water in Philadelphia
so people have gotten a little bit
carried away and I think when you look
at the East if you say it's not like the
West there's not like a big bad you know
wolf out there who's nobody can beat so
I think people are starting to say hey
they can get to the eastern finals and
maybe they can win them so perhaps
expectations have gotten a little bit
out of hand and they might have come a
little bit back to earth last night Bob
good to talk to you thank you for
joining us Dan my pleasure take care
that's Bob Ford Philadelphia Inquirer
columnist he's in a good mood
Philly calm in Philadelphia Inquirer
former Sixers beat writer for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]